this is going to be painful viewing
and we make no apology for that because
this is the war in syria
and dalal is one of the child victims
her parents wanted us to film her they
want the world to see what's happened to
their daughter
her entire body is swayed in bandages
she's so badly burned
all her fingers have been amputated
you can barely see her face and it's too
upsetting to show you
the flames took her eyelids her nose her
lips
and her ears
[Music]
and now she's in the fight of her life
to stay alive
and not yet two years old
inside her small body the fire has done
huge damage to her lungs
she can't breathe on her own and the
turkish doctors are going to try to
perform a tracheotomy to help
her delaul has never known a permanent
home
her family's moved seven times to escape
the fighting
but the doctors are determined to save
her
not good rates to be alive maybe 10
percent
but nowadays of course a little bit more
we have hope
but this doesn't mean we have
passed over all the things no we have a
very very long way
we have to pass but she's
a great warrior and our team is a great
warrior
we rang up her family who are living in
a tent nearly 40 kilometers north of
idlib
and connected them to one of the doctors
treating their daughter
he took them into intensive care for
their first glimpse of dilal
after her surgical procedure
you can see your daughter because
sin they are
overwhelmed with emotion at seeing their
little toddler
but her injuries are horrific although
the doctor desperately tries to cheer
them up
alhamdulillah
[Music]
for foreign mother it's heartbreaking
seeing her child so mutilated is
terribly hard
why is her face like that her mother
asks
she's very very worried her daughter
won't be able to survive this
neither the doctor speaking turkish or
dalal's parents
speaking arabic can understand each
other but the universal language of care
and love needs no translation
[Music]
the fire which engulfed dalal's family
tent was caused by a stove they were
using for heating
rescuers pulled four siblings out but
dalal and her older sister yasmine were
last
and her sister didn't make it
there are millions living in squalid
camps across syria
they're filled with families on the run
from the war
and one of the aid agencies on the
ground told us dalal's tragedy is being
repeated
all across the country if we don't find
a solution soon
how there's going to be many more dallas
aren't there
alex i think there are many more delands
out there
and that is the the most heartbreaking
story is uh
it is important to highlight these
stories it is important to
remember that there are so many dilemmas
out there and it is important to
come together and help these children
it's very touch and go for dilau but
she's at least away from the fighting
now across the border in turkey
and she's already confounded the doctors
here with her strength
they're not going to give up on her just
yet
alex crawford sky news